[Musique]
ce sont mes passagers il faut aller les
libérer
je suis le commandant de borderence en
quoi puis-je vous aider l'extradition
d'un fugitif
[Musique]
il est dangereux qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
homicide il y a 15 ans je ne veux pas
inquiéter les passagers j'ai bien peur
que vous n'ayez pas le choix on commence
l'embarquement et on fait un don à la
[Musique]
on va passer en plein cœur de cette
tempête
tout le monde reste assis sans aucune
exception d'accord
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande de
ne pas détacher votre CE
on a une panne électrique parce que
quelqu'un branche pas qu'on sorte on va
se cacher
ils se sont écrasés quelque part sur
l'île de Johnny
elle est aux mains de séparatiste et de
mélisse l'armée Philippines ne veut même
plus y aller
l'heure tourne chaque minute compte
et on peut décompter ces minutes en vie
perdu ou sauvé
stop reculez reculer on sait pas qui
sait on sait pas qui s'est reculé
écoutez attentivement il s'agit d'une
situation d'urgence je suis le
commandant brodite torrent
j'adore ce gars
non
Angleterre non
je dois aller les libérer ce sont mes
passagers ma responsabilité je vais
avoir besoin de votre Anna c'est de ça
dont vous aurez besoin
vous êtes quoi un ancien militaire on
peut dire ça
pourquoi il vous enfermer on s'en fout
de ce qui s'est passé mais il paraît que
la rédemption peut se trouver là où on
ne l'attend pas
ça votre famille risque de plus voir et
pour la famille qu'est-ce qu'on fait
j'ai une fille et j'ai bien l'intention
de rentrer à la maison
ils vont nous attaquer avec tout ce
qu'ils auront sous la main
on va quitter cette île
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]